[Music]
thank you
one of the main characters in Philip K
Dick's novel The Man in the High Castle
who were introduced to in the very first
chapter in a very packed scene is Frank
Frank and there's a lot of important sub
themes that are all connected together
in this very first vignette telling us
who this guy actually is so we begin
with a crisis that has been imposed on
him he's been fired from his job where
as we're going to learn he creates fakes
fake uh Civil War pistols all sorts of
other things so we find out that he had
done wrong at the factory spouted the
wrong kind of talk to Mr Windham Matson
who had a dished in face with the
Socrates type nose a power a throne
Frank's thoughts wandered groggily yes
he thought and now the Blacklist me my
skill is of no use I have no trade 15
years experience gone now 15 years
experience doing what generating fakes
which are sold in the Antiquities
markets in the Pacific States of America
and there's this entire thing that he's
going to have to do he's going to have
to appear at the laborers justification
commission for revision of his work
category his former boss went to Matson
has a lot of power there and if he fails
to succeed and and pleading his case
then what is he going to do
can he stay in the Pacific States of
America perhaps not he could go into the
Rocky Mountain States but they could
extradite him as well he can't go to the
South and he certainly can't go to the
Nazi United States of America why
because he's a Jew
so we find out his original name was
Frank think he had been born on the east
coast in New York in 1941 he'd been
drafted into the army of the United
States of America right after the
collapse of Russia after the Japs had
taken Hawaii had been sent to the West
Coast when the war ended there he was on
the Japanese side of the settlement line
and there he was today 15 years later
and this is actually very fortunate for
him because if he was on the other side
he would have long ago been executed as
a Jew so he's able to live as a
essentially secular Jew not particularly
religious the only real religion that he
has is Consulting the E Jing and some
sort of speculations about Connections
to his
ex-wife so he's living in the Pacific
States of America and we find out that
his attitude has changed in 1947 on on
capitulation day he'd gone more or less
berserk hating the Japanese as he did he
had viled Revenge he buried his service
weapons 10 feet underground in a
basement well wrapped and oiled for the
day he and his buddies arose and then we
read however time is the great healer a
fact he had not taken into account and
he's accommodated himself in part
because he sees that although you know
he's not at the top of the racial
hierarchy obviously the Japanese are
things are actually fairly well run on
the whole in the Pacific States of
America by comparison to the Nazi held
territories and you know there he talks
about the rugged stoic honesty of the
trade missions right and he says
I guess I really have faith in this
co-prosperity Pacific Alliance stuff he
said to himself strange looking back to
the early days it had seemed such an
obvious fake then empty propaganda but
now and then he starts listening to a
broadcast on the radio and he's got some
Reflections that are in there about what
the Nazis did and where the Japanese are
vis-a-vis the German Reich and then he
starts Consulting the Oracle the Aging
the book of changes which he does at a
number of different points within this
narrative it's something quite important
for him and he asked two important
questions so one of these goes back to
his crisis
how should I approach Windham Matson in
order to come to decent terms with him
and he gets an answer to that then he
asks another question which brings up
another key theme
he sets himself a new question will I
ever see Juliana again and Juliana is
his wife or rather his ex-wife and so we
should move on to that that's another
really absolutely central theme for this
guy so in this part of chapter one we uh
uh read here that
she had divorced him a year ago
he'd not seen her in months in fact she
didn't even know where he didn't even
know where she lived evidently she left
San Francisco perhaps even the Pacific
States of America either their mutual
friends had not heard from her or they
were not telling him and so there's some
reflection here about the E Jing and he
gets a hexagram coming to meet and he
thinks oh man so she was wrong for me I
know that I didn't ask that why does the
Oracle have to remind me a bad fate for
me to have met her and been in love be
in love with her and there's some
interesting Reflections here about what
is going on whether there's some
description that will probably just skip
over here but what's the important parts
for Frank Frank he's in love with her he
fell in love with her he stays in love
with her even toward the end when they
had been fighting so much he never saw
her as any anything but a direct literal
invention of gods dropped into his life
for reasons he would never know
and then here's where it gets really
interesting and on that account a sort
of religious Intuition or faith about
her he could never getting get over
having lost her so even though a year
has passed he can't move on from the
breakup in part because they are
connected and the next paragraph she
seemed so close right now as if he still
had her that Spirit still busy in his
life padding through his room in search
of whatever it was that Juliana sought
and in his mind whenever he took up the
volumes of the Oracle so in a certain
way the E Jing is something that
connects them and we do find out later
that Juliana consults it and in fact has
some pretty important insights and Frank
was the one who got her into that
practice in the first place
there's
um one other really important chapter
for the relationship between the two of
them and this is after
uh he has formed the Ed Frank jewelry
company and they've actually got a nice
stock of things and they're going in to
try to sell it
um to Robert children
and what we what we learn is that
um
he is going to have all sorts of
Reflections about Juliana but first it
begins with thinking about
sending her some jewelry so he's
thinking uh you know if Juliana was here
she could stroll in there and do it that
is sell the stuff without batting an eye
she's pretty she can talk to anybody on
Earth and she's a woman this is women's
jewelry she could wear it into the store
shutting his eyes he tried to imagine
how she would look with one of their
bracelets on or one of their large
silver necklaces with her black hair and
her pale skin doleful probing eyes
wearing a gray Jersey sweater a bit too
tight the silver resting against her
bare flesh metal rising and falling as
she breathed God she was Vivid in his
mind right now every piece they made the
strong thin fingers picked up examined
tossing her head back holding the piece
High Julianna sorting always a witness
to what he had done and he starts
thinking about well what pieces would I
send her best would be earrings you know
and then he thinks about other other
things that they could send to her and
he says you know
I'll send her some jewelry and he he in
fact asks his friend Ed who he's in on
this with
um Can can we send some to her and Ed's
is like I didn't know you were married
and he's well you know I'm going to send
it to my ex-wife so the jewelry becomes
an interesting connection a reconnection
back to her and a way that he could
possibly win her back and now we get
some really interesting reflections
says I know she's living with some guy
sleeping with him as if she was his wife
I know Juliana she couldn't survive any
other way I know how she gets around
Nightfall when it gets cold and dark and
everybody's home sitting around the
living room she was never made for a
solitary life me neither he realized and
then he thinks about who she could be
with maybe the guy is a real nice guy
some shy student she picked up she'd be
a good woman for some young guy who
never had the courage to approach a
woman before she's not hard or cynical
it would do him a lot of good I hope to
hell she's not with some older guy
that's what I couldn't stand some
experienced mean guy with a toothpick
sticking out of the side of his mouth
pushing her around he felt himself
beginning to breathe heavily image of
some beefy hairy guy stepping down hard
on Juliana making her life miserable I
know she'd finally wind up killing
herself he thought it's in the cards for
her if she doesn't find the right man
and that means a really gentle sensitive
kindly student type who would be able to
appreciate all those thoughts she has so
he's wavering between two pictures of
what could be going on the one an older
brutish guy and then the kindly nice shy
student and then he thinks about himself
I was too rough for her he thought
and I'm not so bad there are a hell of a
lot of guys worse than me I could pretty
well figure out what she was thinking
what she wanted when she felt lonely or
bad or depressed I spent a lot of time
worrying and fussing over her but it
wasn't enough she deserved more she
deserves a lot he thought so he's
recognizing the value of this this
person that he was married to and the
kind of other person that she deserves
to get to spend her life with so that's
a very important motivating theme for
this character we also see another plot
or theme coming up in terms of the
criminal actions the illegalities and
being perhaps punished for them so
Windham Matson who
um Frank and uh his his uh you know
partner Ed or going to Blackmail and
children who is going to be part of this
black male scheme the Antiquities dealer
they end up turning Frank in so Windham
Matson has the police look into him and
Frank goes in and pretends to be an
admiral's gentleman so you know this
gets the whole ball rolling with the
possibility of all these pistols and
other memorabilia Americana being fakes
and in time the investigation goes on
and Frank in fact will be arrested
by the police so this is in chapter 12.
and we we see this
um
here we go an ordinary middle-aged white
man sponsored up to him Mr Frank Frank
Frank you got it Frank said the man
produced a folded document and
identification I'm with the San
Francisco Police Department I have a
warrant for your arrest what for Frank
demanded banko Mr Children American
artistic handcrafts the cop forcibly LED
Frank along the sidewalk another planes
close cop joined them one now on either
side of Frank they hustled him towards a
parked unmarked Toyota pet and Frank
thinks that's what the time requires of
us the cops say do you have an attorney
and they talk about you know what
they're going to do and what he did with
the money and then we get to the real
Turning Point
as they got out of the car one of them
said to Frank is your real name think
Frank felt Terror Fink the cop repeated
you're a he exhibited a large gray
folder Refugee from Europe I was born in
New York Frank Frank said you're an
escapee from the Nazis the cop said you
know what this means
Frank broke away and ran across the
garage the three cops shouted at the
doorway he found himself facing a police
car with uniformed armed police blocking
his path the police smiled them and one
of them holding a gun stepped out and
smacked a handcuff in place over his
wrist jerking him by the wrist the cop
let him back the way he'd come back to
Germany one of the cops said surveying
him I'm an American Frank Frank said
you're a Jew the cop said
as he was taken upstairs one of the cops
said will he be booked here no another
said we'll hold him for the German
Consul they'll want to try him under
German law so this looks like a complete
catastrophe at this point but what we're
going to find out is that tagomi
is going to inadvertently save Frank
Frank not knowing who he is but wanting
to take some sort of Revenge or
retaliate against the German authorities
for their attack on the Nippon times
complex which necessitated to gomi
killing to SD agents and then having to
go through this incredible uh
reintegration experience
so we'll talk about what happens after
that but we should now talk about the
jewelry itself so there's this very
interesting
early part discussing this where uh
Frank has gone back hasn't had any
success with Windham Matson and then
um he's talking with Ed McCarthy who
says you should go into business for
yourself
and they go back and forth about this
and you know McCarthy says we should do
jewelry and he He suggests that they
should create a new market take it into
retail shops and then they get to the
heart of this
McCarthy says how long since you tried
to do original designing you know real
creative work and Frank says years I can
copy accurately as hell
so he's great at generating fakes that's
been his trade for the last 15 years
but then McCarthy says something
McCarthy believes in Frank Frank more
than he himself does so he says you know
what I think I think you've picked up
the Nazi ideas that Jews can't create
they can only imitate and sell middlemen
and he says try it do some original
designs or work directly on the metal
play around like a kid plays
and Frank says no and then McCarthy says
you've no faith you've completely lost
faith in yourself right it's too bad
because I know you could do it
and he does do it and the success
is on a very
interesting level you know they take the
jewelry in and
um you know they they children is going
to take It On consignment and children
will end up giving uh some some
pieces to people who can recognize their
genuine value and who can be very
affected by it
so
um what do we find here
before that happens
and just about the time that he's going
to be arrested
Frank gets discouraged he's like we
haven't sold any of this we've been to
five shops already we're just building
more and more jewelry you've got to buy
me out Ed and Ed's like well I mean what
are we going to do split the motor down
the middle and this doesn't get resolved
because Frank gets arrested immediately
after that but what's happening in the
meantime without Frank knowing anything
about it
his jewelry
has captured
or possesses
this
transcendental value this incredibly
important
quality
of whoo
and we find this off because Robert
children has given one of Frank's pieces
to Paul Paul comes back and says I have
inspected this piece for several days
for no logical reason I feel a certain
emotional fondness it doesn't have wobby
nor could it ever but Robert this object
has woo the hands of the artificer had
woo and allowed that woo to flow into
this piece possibly he himself knows
only that this piece satisfies it is
complete Robert by contemplating it we
gain more woo ourselves we experience
the Tranquility Associated not with art
but holy things he goes on to say to
have no historicity no artistic
aesthetic worth and yet to partake of
some ethereal value that is a Marvel
just precisely because this is a
miserable small worthless looking blob
that contributes to its possessing woo
and he goes on and he says
in a lot of cases the Wu is within the
viewer it's a religious experience here
an artificer
Frank Frank has put Wu into the object
rather than witness the woo inherent in
it he says in an entire new world is
pointed to by this the name for it is
neither art for it has no form nor
religion what is it
it is an authentically new thing on the
face of the world
so
Frank not only is still creative
he is able to create in a way that can
be recognized by others and this is what
makes
tagomi's life-changing reintegrating
experience of an alternate reality
possible which interestingly not only
helps to heal to gomi but prepares the
way for tagomi to intervene
to save Frank both of them doing things
that affect each other without ever
encountering each other
and we end with uh chapter 14.
Frank Frank is released that evening
just after the dinner meal a police
officer came to Frank Frank's cell
unlocked the door and told him to go
pick up his possessions at the desk
arrested for no real reason he thought
no purpose and then they let me go the
same way and he thinks to himself a
miracle that they let me go fluke of
some kind by rights I should be on a
plane heading for Germany for
extermination
and he thinks to himself
well this is a new life this is a a
second chance like being reborn and then
he says like hell is
is being reborn
who do I think pray maybe pray to what I
wish I understood I want to comprehend I
have to but he knew he never would just
be glad he thought and keep moving
and so what does he do he goes back to
their workshop and he meets up with that
and he says you know I've reconsidered
um you know what I what I was going to
do let's let's start back up again Ed
says I had the impression you were dead
good to see you back he banged for Frank
twice on the back then returned to his
sandwich and then Frank begins working
again and he's thinking to himself you
know I will pick up where I left off
making the jewelry using my hands
working and not thinking not looking up
or trying to understand I must keep busy
I must turn the pieces out and this is
where we leave off with the
Saga of this character Frank Frank so
absolutely Central to this novel and we
learn so much about him along the way
about the kind of person that he is and
we might even say what his destiny
is going to be